elle est l'une des premières villes des
yvelines à avoir doté ses policiers
municipaux d'armes létales pistolets à
impulsion électrique pistolet
semi-automatique taser flashball bâton
télescopique ou latéral les agents de
triel-sur-seine dispose de toute la
panoplie on s'aperçoit qu'il n'y a pas
d'endroit ni de ville voilà où il peut
rien se passer notamment voilà la
délinquance aller itinérante on a des
accès aux grands passages comme la rue
paul doumer gili a donc on ne sait
jamais à qui on a affaire je crois qu'il
est vital il est nécessaire il est vital
il est crucial même durée pour la pour
la commande à la sécurité déjà la
première sécurité des agents mais aussi
des administrés on est quand même bien
souvent les primo arrivants ou les
primes aux intervenants on les appelle
comme on veut les policiers municipaux
de triel-sur-seine travaille 7 jours sur
7 avec des plages horaires qui
s'étendent jusqu'à minuit en deux ans le
nombre d'agents a également quadruplé il
est passé de 3 à 13 ces mesures leur ont
permis d'intervenir plus régulièrement
la police nationale participent beaucoup
plus à la sécurisation de la commune
puisque avant notre arrivée avant
l'arrivée cette municipalité les
policiers municipaux faisait en moyenne
deux à trois interpellations hareng et l
ain où la dernière 2021 on a fait plus
de 30 pour avoir le droit de porter une
arme chaque policier suit une formation
avec une partie juridique théorique
pratique mais également psychologique
le but d'avoir une arme à la ceinture
c'est pas dû utiliser l'armement c'est
pas de comment dire pardonnez moi je
n'aime pas cette expression là mais
c'est pas dur aux cowboys c'est d'avoir
un moyen ultime est de dernier recours
en fonction de la situation si on
l'utilisent c'est que quelqu'un va
mourir ou nous on va mourir ou une
tierce personne va mourir à
triel-sur-seine chaque agent doit signer
un registre pour signifier qu'il a
récupéré son arme dans les yvelines
plusieurs villes comme rambouillet ou
voisins le bretonneux ont décidé de
renforcer leur effectif et d'armes et
leur police municipale
selon le ministère de l'intérieur 58%
des policiers municipaux sont armés en
france